d'avion
les hôpitaux psychiatriques doivent
disparaître aux drogues progressivement
il faut en finir avec la politique
consistant à rejeter les malades mentaux
ceux ci doivent au contraire être
intégrés dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est la revendication essentielle des
médecins du syndicat de la psychiatrie
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ils ont
manifesté aujourd'hui à paris dominique
thouars
ce matin sur plusieurs marchés parisiens
on vient faire une manifestation pour
sensibiliser la population à
l'enfermement psychiatrique il ya cinq
dix mille personnes qui sont enfermés
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques
dans des conditions d'accueil
déplorables et on pense qu'on peut
trouver autre chose pour les aider ces
manifestants blafard et bâillonné comme
le fou dans l'asile appartiennent au
syndicat de la psychiatrie un mouvement
issu de 68 minoritaire mais actif ils
constatent l'échec ou l'insuffisance des
efforts faits depuis 20 ans dans le
milieu psychiatrique
ils réclament la fermeture progressive
des asiles source selon eux
d'abrutissement et d'oppression le vrai
souligné simplement pour que les gens
prennent conscience du scandale la
situation c'est que sur ses cent mille
personnes il y en a 27 min qui sont
depuis dix ans dans les hôpitaux psy est
je crois pas qu'on puisse dire que c'est
pour les soins je crois qu'il faut que
tout le monde sache que en fait c'est la
rançon d'une certaines exclusions dont
les dif ou sont victimes dans la société
concrètement vous voulez remettre les
malades dans la société avec tout le
monde bien entendu mais concrètement
aussi ça veut dire qu'on ne fera ça que
si véritablement c'est la population
dans son ensemble qui se saisit de cette
question c'est pas nous qui allons
pouvoir magiquement faire sortir tout le
monde des hôpitaux faire sortir tous les
enfants il faut que ça devienne une
question la question de tous
pour atteindre un large public cet après
midi le cortège a circulé dans les rues
de paris jusqu'à l'hôpital sainte-anne
avec la participation d'associations
telles la ligue des droits de l'homme où
le syndicat de la magistrature
mais surtout avec l'animation
d'acrobates de musiciens d'acteurs ou
encore de peintre
les gens qu'on peut rencontrer dans la
rue quand on fait des collages quand on
joue de la musique sont finalement
beaucoup plus ouvert on aurait pu le
penser a priori est plus ouvert que
certains professionnels delà de la santé
cette fête n'est donc un premier pas et
parallèlement une lettre ouverte a été
adressée au président de la république
pour que les malades mentaux sortent de
leur exil